look the facts are i'm uh i grew up in
real estate my dad was a carpenter so i
was swinging a hammer by the time i was
three or four years old right and when i
turned 18 i started selling real estate
to pay my way through college and kind
of fell in love with the industry and
that led to my first company which was a
a digital transaction software called
dot loop which we sold to zillow in
2015. congratulations on there for about
four years thank you
and along the way uh my wife and i it
was about i guess it was about seven
years ago now
in late 2013 my wife and i were like
most families who couldn't afford a
second home we never grew up with second
homes because our family didn't you know
have a lot of extra money
um but we dreamed of owning a second
home and in 2013 we were able to save up
enough money to use as a down payment on
the second home we actually had to rent
the home out on airbnb which was you
know a whole nother experience that we
could talk about but
the owning the second home is a really
life enriching experience for us it it
it what i learned about the experience
is that we didn't just buy a second home
we bought a second community we bought
you know rituals and memories and and
some of our best friends are now in lake
tahoe like lake tahoe is now a really
integral and important part of our lives
and it was made possible because of that
second home so having experienced this
first hand and also recognizing just how
out of reach second homes are because
they're very expensive because they tend
to be in very expensive markets and
they're highly underutilized the facts
are that most second homeowners only use
their home five to six weeks a year
which means that these second homes on
average sit vacant ten to eleven months
per
80
year
90
underutilized or you have to go run an
airbnb which means now your second home
which is supposed to be where you relax
now becomes
uh a business you're running and so for
some people that might be fun if they
have spare cycles but if you're busy and
you got kids that could be a bit of an
albatross exactly exactly so i've been
thinking about this for the last seven
or eight years about this opportunity
and this problem and really my my goal
was twofold it was how do we find a way
to make better use of all these
underutilized homes to empower more
people to realize their dreams of second
home ownership that was like goal number
one but goal number two was really
around utilization you know i've always
been you know obsessed about making
better and more efficient use of things
so that's what led to my first
company.loop it was about more efficient
real estate transactions and it just
drives me nuts to think about all these
homes that are sitting empty because an
empty home
drives up housing prices because it
takes inventory off the market it
constrains um and challenges local
businesses because the bars and
restaurants in these towns during the
shoulder season don't have people to
frequent the restaurants it's bad for
the environment because every home that
sits empty is another home that needs to
be built so it was those two things
accessibility and utilization that that
means trying to solve for and that
really is what airbnb and uber did well
too you know when the reason ubers were
so cheap was because
you were taking cars that would be
dormant 95 of the time cars are even
less used than second homes and
you could put them in the market to be
used another i don't know 10 20 of them
the month
and they can be used for shuttling
people around and then some people don't
have to buy a car and then there's less
cars which means there should be less
congestion or traffic and there should
be more parking spaces available yada
yada yada and that is one of the great
things that technology does so on a
mechanical basis you create an llc
picasso owns no ownership in it you take
no ownership
correct once it's fully sold so got it
to finish the thought on how we created
the company
one of the things i discovered is that
there actually was a solution out there
so i i appreciate you know all the the
compliments up front about creating this
idea but to be honest we didn't invent
the idea of co-ownership i wish we could
take credit for it but we can't
co-ownership has been around for decades
and decades and decades it's actually
very common in almost every market you
know including every market that we
operate in now usually when people
co-own homes it's family members or
friends that are buying property
together so and i'm managing all that
for them like an attorney
well they they do it yourself so like if
you have you and me yeah if you and me
and two of our buddies decided we wanted
to own a house in lake tahoe we could go
do this on our own we would form an llc
we'd draft an operating agreement that
defines how we all you know coordinate
access to the home and we would either
divvy up responsibilities or we would
hire a property manager kind of like
picasso that does the management duties
for us all picasa is doing that's
different is we're taking this old
practice that's been around for decades
and we're applying a service and
technology layer that makes it easy for
people to co-own properties with one
another and you don't have to know who
the other owners are you can own
property now with people who you don't
know and picasso serves as the
intermediary to eliminate all of the you
know the house yeah and i noticed that
when you go to the site you can see you
have some inventory there that you've i
guess pre-bought and that you're selling
in fractional units
now
and once it's sold through there jason
what i was going to say is we do hold
the property for a short period of time
but once all the co-owners are
aggregated the owners own 100 of the
property and we retain no ownership
uh how do you make money
we make money by charging a service fee
so like this home i'm sitting in right
now in fort lauderdale as a picasso it's
a four and a half million dollar home
with picasso you can buy one eighth of
it for six hundred and fifty thousand
dollars and within that six hundred and
fifty thousand dollars about sixty five
thousand of those dollars
is picasso's fee so all the work that we
do to aggregate the buyers to carry the
cost of the property for a period of
time design furnishing you know all that
stuff is baked into our service fee and
it's baked into the price for the people
who who
on a house like that um if i do 650
times eight that's 5.2 million you said
it's a 4.5 million so you make seven
hundred thousand dollars for
finding the house renovating it staging
it uh putting all the furnishing in
doing all the legal uh and to operate
your business uh so that's nice it's
nice to make 700 grand i guess
uh but it's not really a silicon valley
startup if you're just going to make 700
grand per house so how did you get all
these venture capitals to buy into you
getting uh venture capital because they
would say well you get a one-time fee of
700 000. what is the yearly fee to
maintain it and and how did you convince
venture capitalists to get on this ride
yeah so to clarify it's 12 percent so it
in that case it wouldn't be 700 it would
be about you know 500 or so
but so the primary revenue stream that
we have up front is is the service fee
but we have recurring revenue streams
that that go into the future so
management fees we charge about a
hundred dollars per eighth interest per
month to manage the service so that
works out to about ten thousand dollars
per home per year for the oversight and
and the program um we also um offer
financing so about seventy
of buyers who purchase these these homes
end up using financing and that flows
through picasso and we make a little bit
of money on that too and then um
the
the last piece of it is resale
transactions so when somebody goes to re
like let's say you were to buy it
this interest for 650 and then you know
three years from now it's worth 800 and
you decide to sell picasso would
effectively be your real estate agent on
the listing side
or something
yeah a lot of that goes to third-party
agents so we work with third-party real
estate agents on every transaction but
we would get the the listing side of it
and then we pay third party agents on
the buying side of the transaction which
i think is three percent each time about
three percent yeah so you make a little
extra like another 20 grand or something
so you have modeled this and this is
going to be a large robust business
yeah we think so and our investors think
so obviously i mean it's is there some
other business though that you see next
like maybe okay great so you think this
is the sustainable business
absolutely yeah
micro acquire is a startup acquisition
marketplace that cuts out the middleman
basically that means they help startups
get acquired efficiently if you've ever
had to buy a company or you tried to
sell your company there's all these
people in the middle they're not looking
out for you micro acquirer is looking
out for you to date microacquire has
helped hundreds of startups get acquired
and has facilitated hundreds of millions
of dollars in closed deal volume
over a hundred thousand buyers on the
platform right now it's amazing i signed
up for it i paid for it now they're an
advertiser it's crazy thousands of
startups are currently listed for sale
on the site and they've had hundreds of
successful acquisitions so far because
they vet all of the deals they're
putting up there and they vet all the
buyers founders get free and instant
access to these hundred thousand trusted
buyers while staying totally anonymous
this is not like an open marketplace if
you're a founder looking to sell
microacquire is free private and
involves no middle men on the other side
of the marketplace buyers simply pay 290
a year for access the platform like i
did because i might buy some stuff for
inside.com microacquire helps startups
find buyers simple as that they'll help
you start conversations that can lead to
an acquisition in just 30 days for free
at
dot microacquire dot com slash twist
try.microacquire.com
twist go ahead founders and check it out
and if you're an acquirer or you're
looking to beef up your startups
footprint you really should just pay the
290 in peruse and see what you could buy
there it's a really cool service